he was the second largest Democrat donor
he was in the Democrat machine here he
is with lovely lady Maxine Waters I mean
look at this guy look what what a clown
show who are these people anyway
yesterday the hearing that he was
supposed to be at but did not get to
because he's now been arrested what a
wonderful coincidence that was so he
wasn't able to testify under oath uh
Maxine Waters is on the committee that
was leading this thing and she who has
defended him who got money from him how
much is Maxine Waters worth Maxine
Waters who is representative in the LA
suburb which is one of the the poorest
suburbs she doesn't live there though
she lives in Hancock Park which is one
of the richest areas in all of La she's
got to be worth at least 20 million I'm
going to throw out 20 million she's been
she's been in Congress forever how much
is it five no fifty 10 million she's
worth a cool 10 million I don't know how
she did that on a mere government salary
anyway she was uh part of the hearing
yesterday and basically she was trying
to silence other Representatives who
wanted to ask questions it's really
rather remarkable and just smug gross
awful lady goat record the closing
statements from ranking member McHenry
and myself uh and I'd like to thank you
Mr John Ray III chairwoman Waters
presence here today chairwoman Waters
I've not had an opportunity to testify
or to question the witness
I'd like to
um thank you for your presence
chairwoman Waters
parliamentary inquiry yes are all
members entitled to question Witnesses
you are and if you would like to miss
the boats on the floor for everybody
it's the chairwoman's prerogative to
call it one moment that's your decision
not mine
just one moment please you may go right
ahead and have five minutes thank you
thank you madam chair you're certainly
welcome sir you're certainly welcome sir
she's just awful good and had every
right to ask questions and have his
voice heard and everything else but you
very odd to me why would she would want
to shut this thing down real quick and
uh you know for those of you I haven't
done a Star Wars reference in a while
that was literally a scene from Star
Wars the prequels yeah I'm going to the
prequels remember in Phantom Menace when
there's the Trade Federation blockade of
Naboo and queen abidala takes it to the
Senate and they're up there and she's
pleading her case she's going you know
there the the the the separatists
they're blocking us you know what are we
going to do we either attacking us all
this stuff we have no weapons and then
Chancellor of velorium standing there
just like Maxine Waters is and then this
guy comes in his ear and Whispers
something to him which is exactly what
that woman did to Maxine Waters the next
thing you know nothing happens these
people are terrible